With the release of Shazam!, Warner Bros.
has another superhero hit on its hands, further
proving that you don't have to make your movie
part of the MCU to have a good time.
But while the movie's ending is pretty straightforward,
there are enough head-scratching and surprising
moments in the movie's latter third that might
be in need of some explanation.
Don't sweat it!
That's why we're here.
Let's say the magic words — spoilers ahead!
— and explain the ending of Shazam!
If you're not a longtime comic book reader,
you may have scratched your head at some of
the superhero names Billy and Freddie came
up with over the course of the film.
From Thundercrack to the Red Cyclone, none
of them seemed to stick.
By the end of the film, the big dude in red
played by Zachary Levi never seemed to actually
get the kind of codename that gets attached
to other superheroes.
You'd think after so many attempts at getting
him a codename, he'd do better than "Shazam,"
a name he can never say without losing his
powers in a bolt of lightning.
SHAZAM!
So what's the deal?
The short version is that the superhero we
meet in Shazam! didn't always go by this name...in
fact, he used to go by Captain Marvel, back
when he first debuted in 1939.
"Shazam!"
"Billy becomes Captain Marvel!"
But years later, while Captain Marvel comics
weren't being published, Timely Comics changed
its name to the more familiar Marvel Comics
we all know and love.
After Marvel created its own Captain Marvel
character in 1967, DC and Marvel Comics had
to come to an agreement about how to navigate
the tricky trademarks.
Eventually, in 2011 DC just gave up "Captain
Marvel" entirely, and simply renamed the character
"Shazam."
So if you were wondering why he never settled
on the pretty good name of...
"Captain Sparklefingers!"
"No, it’s not.
That's not my name!"
...well, now you know why.
The final battle with Doctor Sivana and the
Seven Deadly Sins provided one of the most
awesome climactic moments in recent superhero
movie history: when Shazam extends his powers
to his foster siblings and creates five more
superheroes to save the day.
Now instead of one new superhero joining the
DCEU, there are actually six.
If you wondered how and why the movie could
justify pulling five super-rabbits out of
its magical hat, there's actually a pretty
nice set-up for this final act twist earlier
in the film that you might've missed if you
weren't paying close attention.
When Billy encounters the wizard Shazam, the
old man yells about the empty chairs behind
him on the Rock of Eternity — chairs that
once belonged to his brothers and sisters
in magic, who have all long-since died.
When Billy shares his powers, he's filling
five more of those seats...though just who
will wind up sitting in that seventh chair
is a question we probably won't have answered
until the next film.
However, since the film seemed to pretty closely
follow the plot of DC's New 52 Shazam! miniseries,
there's a good bet that the current run of
Shazam! comics DC is publishing will offer
some clues as to the seventh Shazam's identity.
...or, it could be Hoppy, the Marvel Bunny!!
Okay, probably not.
But speaking of hidden identities...
The very last scene before the credits rolled
offered up a really fun moment — when Billy's
special guest Superman makes an appearance
of his own.
Of course, while the audience saw Superman's
blue supersuit, the shot was conspicuously
composed to keep the actor's head out of frame.
Considering that Superman is one of the most
popular and important superheroes ever created,
it might've seemed weird to the average moviegoer
that the filmmakers went out of their way
to not show their most bankable hero's face.
The answer is that there's some drama going
on behind the scenes at Warner Bros. and DC
Films regarding just who is going to wear
the big blue suit going forward.
The most recent actor to take the role of
Superman, Henry Cavill, is reportedly in talks
with Warner Bros. about whether or not he'll
return to play the character in future movies.
But while Cavill's future as Superman is murky,
the filmmakers still wanted to have a Superman
cameo in their film, so they did the next-best-thing:
they hired a buff dude to put on the suit,
while simply keeping his face out of frame.
The moment in the film lands as pretty funny
even if you don't know about Cavill's alleged
contract disputes, and it's even funnier if
you do.
And hey, it also meant they didn't have to
spend their CGI budget on Cavill's mustache,
so it's a win-win.
One of the reasons Shazam! is so much fun
is that it's an exceptionally weird movie.
It's got a magic wizard who lives in a cave,
the physical embodiments of religious concepts,
and an unexplained obsession with tigers.
But weirdest of all, it's got a talking, evil
worm, who shows up in the film's mid-credits
scene in Doctor Sivana's prison cell, ranting
about Seven Realms.
As with so many elements of superhero movies,
there was probably a sizeable portion of the
audience that saw this and couldn't be more
confused.
Don't feel bad: this little guy is pretty
bizarre and obscure, even for comic book fans.
Let's just dig into this thing:
The little talking bug is a longtime Shazam
villain named Mister Mind.
He's a talking, super-intelligent worm from
another planet.
That planet is sometimes Venus, depending
on which comic books you're reading.
He's the founder of a team of supervillains
in the comics called the Monster Society of
Evil, which has included members with names
like Jeepers and Mr. Banjo, just to name a
few.
It's...it's pretty wild.
As for the Seven Realms, this seems like it
refers to a pretty recent addition to the
pages of DC Comics' Shazam! series.
As of the making of this video, the comics
are only starting to dig into what these realms
are, or their significance, so if you want
to know more about what's likely to happen
in a sequel to Shazam!, start reading.
Shazam! not only seems to have plenty of potential
for sequels starring Billy Batson, Freddie
Freeman, and the rest of the Shazam Family,
but it also easily connects to the wider DC
Extended Universe.
"I'm Batman!"
"Get'im Batman!"
Aquaman from 2018 proved that DC movies don't
have to be grim and brooding.
But 2019's Shazam! took things to the next
level and showed that DC Comics movies can
have strong connections to each other without
being bogged down in cinematic universe set-up
and continuity gobbledygook.
Meanwhile, there's tons of set-up for future
interactions with other DC heroes.
We already caught a partial glimpse of Shazam
teaming up with Superman in the Fawcett Central
lunchroom.
The second post-credits scene hints at another
possible team up:
"I can't talk to fish!
What can we do with that that's cool?"
"I don't know, maybe command an army of billions
in the ocean?"
"Oh yeah."
While Warner Bros. undoubtedly stumbled out
of the gate with their early efforts in terms
of overall critical reception and box office
performance, Aquaman and Shazam! seem to have
fully righted the ship.
It remains to be seen whether or not the forthcoming
slate of DC movies will actually have any
connections to this film.
But if Warner Bros. can find a way to take
the lessons of Shazam! and make Superman,
Batman, and the rest of the gang fun again...well,
we'll be in for a pretty super batch of movies.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.